my name is melanie i am a recreation
specialist
naked and afraid contestant melanie
rosher has died she was 35 years old
according to tmz melanie's body was
found in arizona a rep for the prescott
police department claims melanie was dog
sitting for homeowners who were away on
vacation upon their return they told
authorities melanie was found dead in
their guest bedroom and their dog was
unharmed
melanie's body was reportedly found near
several cans of compressed air dust
cleaner but her cause of death is still
unknown an autopsy will reveal whether
melanie consumed any of the cleaner but
right now police say there were no
obvious signs of foul play nor a suicide
note left at the scene
we are into communal living for sure now
fear excitement starvation
um fluctuating body temperatures sanity
insanity
the outdoor enthusiast was known for
competing on two seasons of naked and
afraid starting in 2013 and later
appearing on the show spinoff xl in
2015.
there was one person
that i needed it was him
melanie's castmate jerry mckay shared a
heartfelt tribute to his late friend
quote she was my swamp wife a best
friend a strong woman an amazing person
and i'll always cherish our moments
together
jeremy recalls their chemistry on the
reality show and describes their bond as
a friendship that goes beyond words
as the investigation continues we are
sending our sincere condolences to
melanie's family friends and fans who
loved her
[Music]
you